hello and welcome everyone
it is September 1st 2023
we're here in active inference math
stream number 6.1
here with Sean Tull we'll be hearing a
presentation active inference in string
diagrams followed by a discussion this
is super exciting so if you're watching
live please feel free to write your
questions in the live chat
really looking forward to this so thank
you Sean again for joining and to you
for the presentation
all right thanks very much thanks
everyone for watching and thanks to the
organizers for this chance to speak to
you and for the Daniel for getting in
touch and inviting me to speak so
um yeah I'm really excited to share this
work with this community basically and
to hear from those people who work with
active inference and do any formal work
what they what they think of what I'll
present today
um so I'm going to be
presenting a formal approach to how you
can describe active inference in terms
of a entirely graphical language called
language of string diagrams and it's
based on this mathematics called
category Theory and I won't assume that
you're too familiar with this already
and try and introduce it to you in the
talk and ultimately I'd like to sort of
convince you that this diagrammatic
language will be really useful for those
of you who work formally with active
infants I'd encourage you to pick it up
in your own work
I'll just introduce myself about I'm
Sean tile I'm a researcher at Continuum
um formerly a postdoc and computer
science in Oxford and a Continuum in
this Oxford team where I'm based where
we study what we call compositional
intelligence which includes cat applying
category Theory uh to topics in AI
um and as well as this the project was
supported by a grant from fqxi it's
focus at the bottom and posted it at
topless Institute which is the Center
for Applied category Theory
um so let me get started I think so
yeah here we go so um for active
inference I'll won't spend too much time
introducing it I'll assume most people
here are familiar with it and many of
you probably know more about it than I
do intact
um so I just mentioned the parts of it
that I'll be interestingly in in the
talk so thinking of it as a model of
cognition that simply we can think of as
applying many levels say from a whole
organism or just to a single neuron
um and the key idea is that in the in a
you think of an agent as coming with
this generative model that it uses to
explain the observations it receives
from the world in terms of some some
hidden states which you might call
perception and in terms of its own
actions
and
um and active infants it achieves both
of these things for this formal
um patient inference or an approximate
form of Asian inference by minimizing
this quantity called free energy and
these are the ingredients we'll be we'll
be looking at in the talk and the thing
that's really exciting about activism
inside think
um for those of a formal background as
well is that it you know aims to offer
like a very principled approach to
cognition
um that you can hopefully apply at all
these many levels
but I think at the moment it could also
benefit from more uh formal work
and that's what this talks about it's
about formal approaches to theory in
particular I think a nice clear
organizations or active instances would
help to to clarify sort of what the core
or the key ideas of the theory are so
we'd like to be this very succinct
um principle that ideally we just apply
to a generative model and everything
else follows from
um and once we've got to this we can
hopefully generalize it understand it
better
and also make it just more acceptable to
those who come from formal backgrounds
like in mathematics and so on and get
them working on the topic very quickly
and and connect it with approaches in in
artificial intelligence as well
um but the most important thing about a
good formalization I think should just
be to make learning reactive inference
easier make the framework simpler to
understand the sort of what we're aiming
for in this work
and I'd say in them
in other places already there's been
some calls that got some suggestions
that a nice finalization of active
infants should be a diagrammatic one so
when you look at the generative models
that come up in experience a lot they're
very compositional in their nature and
it's very natural to draw them in
diagrams
um so in the United States like our
whole approach to describing it could be
graphical in this way so just for
example this is paper called The
graphical brain by by Kristen power and
abuse and in general you know we've
probably seen loads of these diagrams
describing generative models where you
draw many um compositional features of
different uh spaces of hidden States
observations interacting and so on
so
these diagrams are used but they just
used to represent the model you still
have to then go to doing um sort of
traditional probability Theory
calculations when you reason about them
normally and in fact there is a whole
graphical formalism and mathematical
language for describing these kind of
interacting processes
um just entirely with the diagrams so
the area of an accessible category
Theory and the language are these string
diagrams I'm going to talk today
and in particular there's a lot of work
going on in applied category now in how
you can describe aspects of probability
Theory and causality and causal models
in terms of string diagrams and these
called the models are basically based on
data networks so the same formal
structure as the generative models in
active inference
in particular what we'll talk about
today kind of draws on this paper
Cooperative with Robin Lorenz talking
about causal models and a sense of pearl
in terms of these string diagrams that's
basically caused of Asian networks
um
which has the same formal structure as
we'll be talking about today
so
in this talk I'm talking about this
paper which is joint work with Johannes
Kleiner and services
string diagrams a categorical account
effective processing and free energy and
basically what we do is try to give a
formalization of active inference that's
nice and clear conceptually just
entirely in terms of string diagrams so
we're basically taking the kind of
formal components in something like the
active infants book and turning it into
these diagrams
and as I mentioned it was done as part
of this fqxi project that's actually on
a project about Consciousness it's about
ways that category Theory can be applied
to theories of Consciousness and we've
done some previous work looking at the
integrated information Theory Of
Consciousness and of course there's all
sorts of ways that active inference has
been proposed to connect to
consciousness
um but for the purpose of this talk we
won't go into any of that it's just a
period of cognition I take it to be here
and I'll just mention at the end it'd be
nice to connect it back up to
Consciousness in future
and there's also lots of other related
work going on in KB Theory that's very
close to this that often goes by the
name of categorical cybernetics and this
might include some of the things Toby
has talked about on the on the stream in
the past
so what I do now is introduce categories
and string diagrams and then later we'll
apply them for these basic ingredients
of active infants that I've alluded to
so far so that would be generated models
updating them free energy and active
inference itself
let's start with with these categories
and string diagrams
so you can think of a category in
general as a sort of world of
interacting processes and the categories
we'll talk about here are always going
to be the symmetric monoidal categories
but don't worry too much about the
formal language because the way we talk
about them is just going to come down to
the diagrams here today
so a category amounts to a collection of
these objects or sometimes called
systems like this Capital ABC here
and what are called morphisms or you
might monitor typical processes between
them so when you're writing normally you
can just write a more person from A to B
it's like this at colon A to B in string
diagrams so you draw it like this where
we're reading all the diagrams from
bottom to top in in this talk so you
have a wire for the a input at the
bottom and a YF heavy B output at the
top and the morphism is just drawn as a
box F here and you just read the diagram
up thinking about okay it takes in this
input coming in on this y a process
applies and then you have your output
type B at the top
yeah
so what you can do with these processes
is compose them so if you have two
processes
um they get F from A to B and G from B
to C so the type of sign up you can just
compose them in sequence and this just
means plugging the boxes together in
your diagrams and because we're in this
monoidal category you can also compose
in parallel so you have this operation
called the 10th so which means given to
objects you can put them together to
build this composite object so AV goes
to a TENS of B you'd say and you can
also do this to morphisms so you can
build this F tensor G
um but in the pictures it just means
growing them side by side and you just
think of this as meaning we have F from
a to c and G from B to D and they're
just running in parallel and they're not
interacting essentially
um so most of the time you just draw a
picture like this and you don't even
need to write the tensor symbols so if
these two basic modes of composition and
from these you can build much more uh
elaborate string diagrams in your
category
so if you're writing things very
mathematically if there were relative
equations that these that are category
or minodial category needs to satisfy
but when you work in the diagrams they
basically do some of the work for you
because these things just come out for
free so for example you have equations
like this that you'd have to think about
when you're working uh with them in the
conventional mathematical way but in the
diagrams it just means if you have two
boxes you can kind of slide them along
the wires it doesn't really matter where
they are on the wires it tends to just
be the connectivity that matters
similarly we can crosswise over each
other because we're in symmetric setting
and uh there's a few like
um just useful features that you always
have in a category so every every object
comes with this identity morphism you
should just think of as meaning nothing
is nothing happening basically so it's
just drawn as a blank wire there's also
a kind of identity object as it were
called a unit object which is just empty
space so you don't even draw the wire
it's just this Dash box just means
nothing it's going to be an empty
picture
and another thing is just useful because
it now means we can talk about morphism
which doesn't even have an input or an
output more formula has this object I as
it's input might not put and we give
these things special names so the most
important one probably is that of a
state
um which is a morphism with no input as
it were already with input I so in the
pictures it just looks like this so
there's no y going in and you call this
a state of a
you can also have a process that takes
in a if it has no output that you call
an effect and if you have an eye you
just call this a scalar so this is this
is just going to be like a number
basically floating around next to your
diagram
so there's there are many categories out
there the point category is extremely
General so this could be talking about
computational processes or physical
processes or Quantum processes in
particular and all sorts of things but
this talk will only actually need to do
about one category we'll just keep it
simple with this one that's the category
I call it matar plus so it's positive
three or matrices
so you can just take objects so the
wires to be finite sets and the more
things that morphisms to be positive
matrices indexed by these as I explained
so if we draw a box like this m going
from X to y
this is like a matrix indexed by X and Y
for each input in the cells of set X so
in the set X and each output in y you
get a positive real number and you and
we'll write it like M of Y given X
so this box would mean a function like
this
now when we plug them together they let
us turn some things that you normally
have to do with equations it's a kind of
simpler pictures I mean mainly this
middle one so if we have two in sequence
we just compose them by matrix
multiplication so instead of having to
write this formula what we sum over y we
can just draw this picture above it
where we just float them on top
and if we run them in parallel here we
take the Cartesian product of the sets
and the tensor product of the matrices
as it were but it's just the obvious
thing where you have two
um things running independently
so in particular a state here ends up
the the minority unit is Singleton set
and you can basically just ignore it so
a state here amounts to just a function
sending each X to a positive real and
effect the same thing and a scalar would
just be a positive real
the intuition knows that we're going to
restrict to the particular more business
in here which are probabilistic in the
nature so they need to send each X to
actual distribution over y so I want to
talk about how you actually pick those
out next so to do that you use some
extra structure that this category has
it forms what's called a copy discard
category so this is one more bit of
mathematical sort of gadgets we have
around so that is that each object comes
with these distinguished processes it's
one that we call copy that takes in a
saying we've got two copies of a at the
top and one called discard where you
just throw a away so you have no output
at the top
um these satisfy some equations
um that are quite intuitive if you think
about like copying and then throwing
away one of the outputs is the same as
doing that thing so let's explain why
I'm copying is symmetric and associative
is the Earth One so in this category
matter plus discard would be just the
function sending each element to one
and the copy would be like a Delta so a
comes in and two copies of eight come
out at the top is the intuition
the reason we introduce this stuff is
because it's been shown recently you can
do a lot of probability Theory uh just
in terms of these CD categories and
particular ones called Markov category
so there's a lot of what's going on in
applied to category Theory at the moment
it's using this language of CD
categories
foreign
let me pick out some things to do with
probability Theory I'll just talk about
a couple of them here the most important
one is the notion of a channel
so this is what lets us pick out the
actual normalized uh matrices as it were
from earlier
so in general you call a more business
Channel when it preserves it's
discarding
and a special case is a state in which
it's a channel you call it normalized so
for a state this means it would actually
be a probability distribution so it's
actually normalized if you sum over the
values with this Omega you'll get one
and for for a morphism being a channel
it means it sends each input to a
distribution so it actually is a
probability channel in a usual sense
uh equivalently The Matrix for f would
be stochastic
so these are the ones who would use in
generative models for example
and this as I said Associated
probability for you can describe these
with these diagrams it's very two simple
examples you can describe
marginalization in probability Theory
with this discarding thing so if you
have box Omega like this it would be a
joint distribution over X and Y if you
just describe y you'll get the marginal
on x
and if you plug uh Omega a distribution
on X into an effect that would just be
any function on X this would be giving
you a scalar now and that would be the
expectation value of the in this
distribution
so I'll meet lots more of this as we go
but let's actually start doing some
stuff uh rated active inference in
particular now so I want to talk about
generative models and how you view these
in the diagrams
so as we've said uh we're going to talk
about agents having different models
that relate things like actions
observations and World States
and these are normally quite
compositional and active infants right
and it might involve many different
spaces of states and observations and
these processes relating them and you
usually treat these with something like
evasion Network
um claiming you can view it really as a
causal version Network because it's sort
of describing how states are causing
these observations
um performing it's the same thing so
spatial Network which you could normally
say a subscriber something like a dag
the director is like a graph
which describe the different variables
that are being related and then sets of
values for each and probability channels
described in each one in terms of its
parents in the dag and then you often
look at this whole distribution over
over all the variables
but already I'd say the way that these
uh data networks are drawn in active
infants text and stuff is kind of
converging on something a bit closer to
string diagrams because you don't
actually
um just draw the Diagon the variables
it's very useful to actually give names
to the mechanisms themselves as it were
like you have in this picture the A and
the B's
um so yeah my claim is sort of
converging on the way that string
diagrams will look as we'll see on the
next slide which is where you really do
label everything
um not just the the variables
so to describe those sort of Bayesian
networks with string diagrams the key
observation is really that dags
correspond to a certain class extreme
diagrams that we'll call Network
diagrams
um there's a definition here but we're
just better just to see an example in a
second but the diagrams built from
copying and sometimes discarding and the
key thing is just that they only have
processes with maybe many inputs but
only one output
so this is going to be like a mechanism
that produces each variable
so the result is that if you have a dag
G and you choose some of the the
vertices to the outputs so there's like
The observed variables you can draw a
network diagram which expresses the same
equivalent structure with those things
as the outputs so here's an example we
have a dag with these four variables X1
to X4
and what you do is you have a wire for
each variable in your diagram on the
right
and you draw a box that produces it
doesn't really matter what you label the
Box
um
so with this box C for example which
uses X2 and you'll produce it in terms
of its parents in the dag so X1 and X4
in this case and if it doesn't have any
parents it would just be a state as it
work box or no input
and then what you do is you take each
row or you copy it and you pass it
toward its children in the dag and also
out of the diagram if it's an output so
this now means you've sort of expressed
the whole structure of the of the day
and also which variables are sort of
leaving the system the output ones
so this allows us to turn dag into a
string diagram and then if you want to
make a generative model like that
expresses the you know like a baby
Network that's structurally go into this
dag you just have to now interpret this
diagram in a certain sense so in general
working in any one of these CD
categories there's copy discard
categories we can say that a generative
model in there is given by one of these
Network diagrams without any inputs
and an interpretation of the diagram
meaning you actually say what the
objects are for each of the wires in the
diagram and what the actual channels are
so they need to be channels not just
morphisms
um in your category are for each of the
boxes so for a gender model like this
you would say you pick objects X1 x64
and pick channels for the ABCD
and we'll think of the outputs of the
diagrams like The Observer variables and
the rest of the Hidden ones
so for example if you're working in this
category matter Plus
that is there any category I've actually
introduced here so this is going to be a
running example this is the same thing
as one of these cause evasion networks
so it just means picking sets of values
for variables and picking property
channels for the boxes
um so you might ask why would you use
this representation rather than the
usual one I think it's a good question
so it's equivalent to the the DAC
um and probability Channel description
um but the thing that's nice is that in
the conventional approach these networks
you sort of have to switch between the
dags which is for the variables and then
doing calculations with probabilities
whereas and the categorical approach you
can use just one formalism because you
can do probability Theory with a string
diagrams as well so it's quite natural
in that sense you have this one language
that both just intuitively drawing
what's going on in a model and then
reasoning about it
it also lets you start to generalize
things in a useful way I think so we I
kept having to say that you have no
inputs to your diagram but there's
nothing really fundamental about that
one it's not really clear why we need
that so what we what you can do instead
is start to allow inputs to your model
as well so we'll
um call this an open generated model so
an open generative model
is the same thing but now just drop this
requirement the diagram doesn't have any
inputs
so here's an example of a general
Network diagram now with these inputs
x2x3 so there's no mechanism specified
for these new variables X2 X3 they're
just input variables to the system
and they can be outputs as well for
example X3 is broken input and an output
here and again an interpretation of this
General Network diagram this means
picking the objects and the channels
and this is the same definition we use
to define what we call an open cause a
model in in the paper with Robin Lorenz
that I mentioned earlier so enabled
generative model is formally just the
same thing but we're just thinking of it
as a generative model possessed by a
cognitive agent
if you run the definition in math.plus
then this is just like it goes on laser
Network and now you have some of your
variables just have no mechanisms
specifies so they're just inputs to the
whole thing
um a nice thing about these open
generative models is that because they
can have these inputs you can plug them
together and compose them and these
things in fact form their own category
but I won't go into that today
um so that was the general theory of
these generative models that just
actually describe some examples that
you'll you'll see in active inference
coming up all the time
so it's a simple example let's just
imagine we have one space of hidden
States and one space of observations
then it would be a generative model that
form which is that like this network
diagram where it's just two wires
there's just Sno
um s doesn't have any parents so it just
has this prior distribution Sigma over
it and it's just this one channel
often called the likelihood from s to O
if you just draw that Network diagram
and say that that model in in C that or
in Mata plus it would be the same as
it's one of these simple generative
models when you're looking at these
you're often introduced interested in
this distribution over both variables
together this joint distribution that
you might write as you know P of s times
P of O given s normally or a bit more
specifically here introducing their
names for the two distribution in the
channel here
and string diagrams is just the same as
this so you just take the prior and you
make it an output now and then you
compose those channels together and this
would give you a distribution so a
normalized state m
um over Sno at this so this is just the
resulting joint distribution you get
from the generator model and we'll come
back to that later
um so a more
elaborate example of generative model
that you'll see for example in the
active infants textbook are these
discrete time models that are used a lot
so I'll walk through this diagram now so
this is an example of a more complex
Network diagram and a generative model
it describes so here we've got these n
time steps going uh remember we read
from bottom to top but I'll just talk
about the I'll describe things from the
top down here so the top we have the
observations o102 up to om
the observations at each time being
caused by these hidden States S1 S2 and
SN at each time by these channels a
um
and the hidden state is evolving over
time by this transition Channel B where
it takes the previous state as an input
and then choose the next one it also
takes us one extra wires on the bottom
and that's the space p of policies which
is how the agent sort of actions enter
the pictures these policies describe its
behaviors its behavioral policies it can
carry out so based on the previous
interstate and the way it's acting this
channel B would determine the
probabilities for the next States
and then there's a prior over
um the policies that you can think of as
a habits or the typical behaviors of the
system
so you can just draw this diagram and
say like interpret this in Mata plus and
that would for any given interpretation
meaning any choice of what the values
for these variables can possibly take
are and any choice of what these
channels are but then give you this this
type of primitive model
and
um often you will see models sort of at
this form or similar forms being plugged
together from these hierarchical models
and I think the compositional language
is very nice for these because you
really want to talk about open models to
Define this so hierarchical model you
can view as really as just being given
by taking us to these open genitive
models I mentioned and plugging them
together in a certain sense so here you
can see a picture of a hierarchical
model where we just have these layers
where different copies of the same model
at each layer and the inputs from one
layer match the output to the layer
below so we can compose them together
first generative models
um so so far we've just been using the
diagrams to represent them we'd like to
actually do a bit more their own reason
about these models and particularly talk
about how you update a model or update
the beliefs within a model
um which is very important in active
inference and how this looks in the in
the string diagrams now
so let's say we've got an agent M we
have a model m
and it's just the simple one where we
say there's just one space of hidden
States s and one space observations o so
they have this joint distribution that I
mentioned earlier
and they have these prior beliefs about
s which you can get back from the joint
distribution by it's taking the marginal
if you like so that's a signal so we've
got their model they've got their
beliefs about what states are likely and
then they receive a new observation and
here the kind of observations we'll
think about in general can be soft
meaning they're described by a
distribution over not necessarily just
one element
so that would be one of these normalized
um States but we'll try not to use the
word State here because it's a bit
confusing with this s around so this
distribution over o
is then your observation this bold font
o
another one update the margin they want
to update m in some ways so that the
marginal basically is
different and describes the updated
posterior beliefs and this comes up of
course in perception where you're
completing your sort of state of the
world given to Observation you receive
they could also be used to model like
planning Behavior where updating your
plan of action your policy uh given
something like which outcomes you'd like
to see in the future
and we'll come back to that later in the
talk
so we want to talk about how you can do
this updating
so you might think there's just a
standard answer or at least in the ideal
case which is this Bayesian updating and
that's true when your observations are
sharp and we'll start by talking about
that case so I'll see what sharp means
in a second but first we'll just talk
about how you treat Bayesian
conditioning in these string diagrams so
on the right here we have uh if you do
this process from o to S this describes
the sort of Bayesian conditional
a Channel or in general the partial
Channel impact
um that the agent would have
from the introduced by their model so
you can describe this in string diagrams
with a couple of extra gadgets I hadn't
mentioned yet
so you have your distribution M over Sno
you can have this a mapper plus there's
this effect that we call the cat which
is just takes two inputs and Compares if
they're equal and as allows for you to
turn an output into an input so that's
what this part here is
and then you can introduce this extra
thing of normalization so what you'd
like to do is
take a general morphism and for each
possible input normalized factor that
it's a distribution if you can or set it
to zero if it's just zero and there's
nothing you can do that's what this blue
dash box is
um and in the paper and in the in the
related course and models paper we talk
about the the axioms normalization
feature satisfies
and the point is if you compute this
thing in Mata plus it will give you kind
of what you'd expect so it'll give you
the usual notion for each
you plug it into this you'll get a kind
of conditional M of s given o that you'd
expect whenever that's defined
there's a string diagram way to describe
this kind of Bayesian conditional
Channel or partial Channel
and I said this is what you would use
when your observation is sharp and I I
also drew it definitely with this
triangle to sort of distinguish that
case so what does that mean so in
general you say that a a state in one of
these CD categories
um so a distribution basically would be
sharp when it's copied by copy map which
isn't true for General distributions
and if you run this definition in method
plus this really means that this thing
already is just point distribution at
some specific element of O so you know
it really is sharp in that sense it's
just a point there's no real
probabilities yeah probabilistic aspects
to it there
in any CP category you can just talk
about the sharp States like this they're
often also called deterministic
so for these sharp ones you know you
ideally think you'd like to do this
patient updating but in fact when you've
got soft ones so it doesn't have this
property uh there's actually two at
least two good ways to do this kind of
updating I don't know if this is as well
known so I'll just mention it um now
anyway and they've been studied in some
detail by Bart Jacobs this paper at the
bottom
so let's say you don't get one of these
sharp observations you have just a
distribution over o there's these two
reasonable ways to generalize sort of
the picture from the last slide to give
a notion of updating and yeah because on
Jeffries and Pearls update rules
so in Jeffrey's update you basically do
it like we did before you you have this
Asian conditional kind of Channel or
partial channel the normalized boxer and
you just plug the distribution into it
other than Pals update you turn a
distribution into an effect so you just
compose it with this cap to bend it
around in the picture that's what it
means
so you plug that into M and then
normalize everything so the difference
is where the normalization
happens and yes it's basically just
interesting that both of these are
reasonable Notions generalization they
have different properties it's not
obvious that one of them is sort of more
rational or something than the other
they just behave a bit differently
um in the formula you can see that the
normalization is being applied
definitely so if you turn this picture
into the usual notation that will look
like this
um so in the top case you're normalizing
for each possible sharp o and then
taking an expectation over this
distribution here as anything whole case
you plug the whole thing together and
then just normalize
the way you do it though the points that
these things are actually hard to
compute so don't expect the cognitive
agent to be doing either these exactly
even in the sharp case
and so as we know we want to instead
approximate these kind of things using
free energy so I'll talk about next
um so we are able to try and accommodate
free energy somehow in a diagrammatic
approach and the free energy sort of
formerly that come up are often given in
terms of what you call the surprise
these negative logarithm quantities so
we'll start by introducing just a new
graphical component for treating those
that we call log boxes do you have any
function e on the honestly x a positive
real remember that made in a that would
look like an effect in your category X
um
then what we want to do is talk about
this function X goes to minus log of e
of x
let's record the surprise so just
introduce this graphical feature where
we draw a green box around it and say
that denotes this function now
and using rules the nice property is the
logarithm you can turn this into nice
graphical rules this this lockbox
feature would satisfy
um for example this is sort of the way
that an algorithms have multiplication
into addition on the left here
um if you have this around then you can
start talking about surprise so if you
have two distributions Sigma and Omega
you can do the surprise that's the one
distribution relative to the other is
defined by this expectation value so
these just the expectation of a surprise
of Sigma
according to Amazon if you remember I
said expectation values are given by
sort of plugging a state for the
distribution into the thing you're
looking at the expectation value of so
that would be the log box here so we can
just Define surprise uh and we're
assuming that in this way for in the
pictures an important special cases for
this camera bar when you're calculating
entropy which is the self-surprise and
the chaotic Merchants can be calculated
from a surprise in the entropy
so it means that whenever we have
formula given in terms of these if we
like we can instead denote them with
this this graphical symbol at least with
the log box
so now let's talk about how we use this
to describe free energy so what we want
to do in the paper is sort of help
clarify the kind of different Notions of
free energy that we found in in active
inference in particular the variational
and the expected free energy so we want
one more General quantity that we can
understand both of those in terms of I'm
just calling that the free energy uh
here I'm interested to know what other
people think of this sort of naming for
what we're doing
the situation is that we've got some
generative model that's fixed over these
two variables Sno like before so
remember we had this distribution this
box m
uh over Sno it's distribution and let's
just say we have another distribution
queue now and we'll see examples of this
in a second what sort of queue they
would be
then we just Define this quantity you've
got the free energy of the one relative
to the other in this way so it's the
surprise uh minus the entropy of Q in
the string diagrams then it's just this
feature we plug so it's like the
expected surprise of M for Q minus the
entropy of Q's marginal on S
or this is performing art if you want to
use the the conventional notation which
is useful for relating it to
existing approaches
so we can Define this very general free
energy quantity and then we'll meet two
special cases of it that we're
interested in which is the variational
and expected
free energy
it all comes down basically to having a
definition of surprise you know you just
need this notion of surprise to Define
everything else
so the variation of free energy
so we have this fixed model M and we
have the soft observation o like we did
before so this box here
and then what we're doing is we're
considering different possible
distributions over s that we think of as
different updates we could consider for
our beliefs and we Define the variation
of free energy of any of those States
those distributions Q
as the special case of the definition
for the previous slide so it's like the
general free energy
where that capital Q just takes this
form so it just consists of our new
beliefs lowercase q and our observation
O
So in Formula you can just draw like
this so you take the surprise from your
model M and you just see how it its
expected value for those beliefs and
that observation
subtracted the the entropy of Q
um
and what you're going to show is that
this vfv value satisfies this bound with
the KL in relation to the kind of
Jeffrey update I mean model with respect
to this observation
in particular when
um it's a sharp observation then the
minimal of this
BFF will be given by the the Basin
updating
[Music]
in general though we might think about
what happens
um so in general we can think of
minimizing this the SP quantity it's
doing this as finding this queue that
approximates this kind of update so
we're looking at earlier
and yeah in the sharp case it will
coincide as all of the Notions of
updating do
um so the minimal vfp will be given by
the Bayesian update but for these soft
observations
um it's something else that's not
exactly the the either the two Nations
updating we met earlier so this is
actually a third notion of updating for
soft observations
um which I think is an interesting way
to think about vfp minimization is doing
so we just call this the vfv update so
you've got many different queue you can
calculate the sphere of the quantity for
each and you've got a soft observation
over here so it's some distribution
and if you find the one with the minimal
value of sphere that you call that the
fear fee update
and this wouldn't be equal to either
those Pearl or Jeffrey style updates
that we met earlier
so that's the vfv which will which we'll
come back to the other notion of uh free
energy we want to talk about the
expected free energy
so that's where we still have our model
M but rather than an observation we
think of ourselves as having some
preferences of observations we'd like to
see they're again encoded in a
distribution though over over o so
that's just C
and that and so
in just with that fixed we can Define
this one quantity called the expected
free energy
so that's given by the free energy of M
compared to this other generative model
where you have to use the same in so
this m here would really be the inverse
channels from o to S of M so like the
Bayesian inverse here
um but where you just assert that the
preferences actually is the Pariah on
the observation so you're comparing
these two
um in terms of this generic free energy
quantity we defined earlier
so again you can turn this into formulas
and there's loads of stuff going after
inference about the different rewritings
of the efe and the ways to interpret
with them in terms of uncertainty and
risk and so on
and it has this property that you can
show it'll be a bounded by
um the surprise of those preferences for
your your model so and it kind of gives
you a way to approximate them as we'll
see so I went and talked I don't have
time to get too much at efe but the
point really in terms of what this
work's done is just to try and um
have just one generic free energy
quantity we met earlier where we can see
the vfp in the ESU book coming out the
special cases depending on what we plug
in here for the the two distributions
so what I'd like to do now is to sort of
put some of these pieces together to
show active inference itself will kind
of look like in terms of string diagrams
and particular what we'll do is derive
this formula that you'll find in
actually inference textbooks um in a
graphical in a graphical way and I think
uh quite a transparent way but that's
the claim
so and to do so we basically need to
give a nice high level conceptual
viewable active inference is so this is
the way that we do it in the paper
so when inactory interference team the
key thing for statement with admissions
is that our model takes the following
the form at a higher level so there's
some notion of so it's like our discrete
time model we had earlier but just with
two time steps if you like each of those
time steps could break down in terms of
further sub time sets but that won't
matter we've just obstructive here uh at
this higher level
so at the higher level we just have a
notion of the current time or maybe like
all the time steps up to the current
time and that's this s and O here so
there's current states and current
observations
then it's the notion of future times
these future States and future
observations so that could be all the
time steps up to some big number
something like that all grouped together
in one of those discrete time models
and again we have the policies and we
have the same sort of shape of model
where there's
some channels here which you haven't
bothered of giving letters to but
showing the way that the policy
um
influences the transition from the state
to the Future State and observations
from each
so we just have a generative model where
we have policies that we have States and
observations and we have future States
and future observations in active
inference what we're doing is we're
receiving two things we're receiving an
observation in the current time and we
have some preferences about what we'd
like to see in the future
so these are each given by these two
distributions however Voltron 0 over 0
and the preferences C over the future
observations
and then we're doing updating with those
so I think that dating is just our
um our habits the the prior over the
policies
to give our new distribution over
policies which we can think of as the
agent's plan of how it wants to act so
we're going to try and do this updating
like before to obtain a new distribution
over p
and that is now telling us how we want
to behave in the future in a way that
well basically you can think of it as
saying we want to explain why we're
seeing what we're currently seeing and
how we're going to obtain what we'd like
in the future
so in the in the book stand for infants
and various places you can find a
formula like this that will be justified
as coming from the free energy principle
in some way but basically saying you can
do this um approximately by making a
plan distribution take the following the
form so there's a soft Max there's a
apartment relating to the habits of your
model so that's your prior over policies
these Pi are the individual policies in
p
and then there's two there's parts of
One Direction to the vfv and the efe
um and what we wanted to do is see where
this formula comes from in a sort of
nice uh I love away from the structure
of the diagram so the usual there are
explanations for this formula there but
I found them quite hard to follow to be
honest because they were talking about
the
um efe as being a prior that you then do
um DFE carbonization on top of but you
kind of need to do the the forward the
part about the present time first before
you can do the ESV
and so what we wanted this is a really
clear way to see how this just drops out
from the structure of the model so
that's what I'll try and show now
so
what we'd like to do then is to do this
approximate updating we're going to do
the Pearl style updating which look like
this in the pictures so we want to get
our new plan so our distribution over
policies by updating by plugging in
observation and our preferences
and then normalizing everything so the
thing on the right is what we'd like to
have ideally but we're just gonna have
to approximate it in some way
so let's just take the distribution
that's inside the dash normalization box
now
this is the thing you know we'd like to
basically approximate this
in the structure of our model we can
write it like this
and I'll just show then some graphical
steps for how we can apply
approximations to obtain the formula
that we saw and obviously we weren't
able to go through every detail of the
proof but it should give hopefully some
intuition for what it's like to actually
work with a string diagram so that's
really why I'm showing it so we knew our
model take roughly this form there's
some part relating to current states and
current observations and also future
observations I just called them both M
here
um but yeah we just noticed that part
to the present time and future time
and so what we're going to do is first
focus on this part of the model relating
to the current state and the current
observation and we want to approximate
what's in that blue dash box and what
you can show is that if you do this via
the updating that will be approximately
equal to this part of the diagram
so this Q is given by for each policy
doing this um BFE updating so minimizing
your variation of free energy
so you do that for each policy and then
you can view the collection of all of
those up belief updates as just one
channel from P to s
so if you think about back here
basically for each policy you could plug
in you would obtain just a distribution
now over Sno and you could do updating
with respect to that that's what Pew of
that particular policy Pi would be
and you put them all together into this
one channel queue
and you can show then for each one if
you do this overall process where you
multiply by this e to the minus V of the
quantity here it will be approximately
uh equal to this this part of the
diagram
okay so that's our first step and that's
how the vfb entered the picture then
we've got this top part of the diagram
we'll collapse it together and just view
this as one process going into future
observations
and our preferences and we'd like to
approximate what's in this box now
and this is where the efv comes in so
you can basically show because we have
this
um yeah that the expected free energy
will give you an approximation to this
here where this is basically like an
expectation value for your preferences
um for each policy so this would be like
the density C of the preferences being
plugged into your model
for each policy
um
so I have no time to go into the full
details the approximation steps but
they're essentially the same
approximations you'll find in you know
active inference text and so on just
turn it into the string diagrammatic
setting and we talk about how you figure
out how how they come about from
Jensen's inequality and things like this
so this step where you think about the
future times sometimes it's got the
prediction step and the previous one was
the was the perception step
so now we've Rewritten that diagram in
terms of some e to the minus of the v f
e and e to the minus of the efv as well
as our habits
um I'll remember what we wanted to do
was approximate the normalization of
this whole thing so that's when you
apply this blue dash box around the
whole thing
and now if we do that we this is exactly
the same as the formula we're after so
we've obtained the formula now
um and that's because you know you're
normalizing something but it's got these
e to the minuses in it so you can also
rewrite that in terms of the softmax
where now that you just replace the E
with this log and the other ones you
lose the exponentials
so this formula if you wanted to yeah if
you're on a Roadhouse one of what this
was for each policy it would be equal to
this down here so
uh the claims that this is a nice way to
derive this formula and it's a bit more
transparent than the the ones that exist
so the idea was really just to see we
draw what's going on okay we're doing
updating with the model of this form
and we're trying to do this approximate
form of updating and just see where
we're applying the approximations and
from the structure of the model itself
to see how this formula comes about
um
okay so that so far basically just
talked about things that are already
there in active infants such as new
derivation but it's existing and stuff
before wrapping up I just like to also
talk about something a bit more new that
we do with the string diagrammatic
approach
first to talk about the way in which
free energy itself uh is compositional
so the motivation of this is that you
know the idea is that we want to think
of this one free energy principle
applying at all levels of a system
um so to do that you'd want to know that
an agent can say if you've got one of
these big composite generative models
that it can do its free energy
minimization on the whole thing by doing
it on the parts because we want to
ultimately think it just comes down to
each part doing its own bit of free
energy minimization so that's what we
want to make precise
and particularly we're going to be
talking about the the vfe here really
all the time
and if you recall in the diagrams that
look like this so we use these log boxes
and it just had took this particular
shape here
so what we do in the paper
in order to address this
compositionality problem
is introduce a notion of this BFE that
we can apply not just to generative
models but once which actually have
these inputs as well so these are what I
call open generated models earlier
because we need to really talk about
pieces of generative models plugging
together and give them a notion of free
energy to even make sense of this notion
of free energy being compositional
so we propose this definition of what we
call the open vfe
but now instead of just a distribution M
over s and O we have a channel from some
inputs to Sno given by one of these open
models
and our Q the thing we're doing the Via
humanization
um with respect to so the thing we're
calculating it would now have in an
input as well so it's a joint
distribution over the states and inputs
and observation takes the same shape as
before
um so you get this other formula that's
basically just a natural way to
generalize the previous vme formula to
accommodate this extra input wire I now
um
and what we show is that this thing is
compositional in the sensor that I
alluded to so I'll walk through that and
the way you do it is just using these
graphical properties that these log
boxes have that I mentioned earlier so
you could turn all that into a proof in
standard probability notation if you
like but it's quite uh instructive to
always just be able to work in the
diagrams to keep track of the
compositional structure of the models
and so on
so the result says that this open vfe
quantity is compositional in two ways
first one here is this quite trivial way
so if we have two models running in
parallel so like taking a tensor of them
and they're just both doing their own uh
or kind of taking the bfv for each of
them sorry for the whole thing but it's
just given by two running in parallel
then it's just the same as calculating
the V of each individually and adding
them together so that should that is
certainly what we'd like to happen and
it just follows from the properties of
these log boxes
more interestingly there's the second
way in which it's compositional which is
the sequential mode of plugging models
together so if we have an open model M1
and some inputs into some outputs o1 but
those are now actually the inputs for
the second model I have these running
for the first generated model is still
passing step up to the second one
and now we want to calculate that
results vfb
in terms of an observation
and we can again write it as a sum of
two of them but in a slightly different
way so observation is just existing on
the top why all right because it's just
the output of the whole thing against
this observations it's just on O2
so first we calculate the vfv for this
model at the top M2 in the usual way
and then we add on a vfv calculator for
the first model but it doesn't really
have an observation o1 right but instead
the observation it uses is one that's
being passed down
from empty so that's the
um the queue that M2 is using is passed
down now as if it's an observation down
so M1 so it's kind of like O2 receives
this observation does its uh
updating about queue or whatever and
passes that down to M1
so in this way we can say that the vfp
composes in that okay both of these are
minimizing vfp locally
where for the M1 model we mean it's
minimizing it with respect to these
views that are coming but these o ones
that are coming down from above
then the whole system is also minimizing
its fear because it's just given by
summing those two together
so I talked about a lot of stuff now I'm
just going to wrap up now and then we
can go to a discussion I hope
um so the main takeaway was just meant
to be to try and show that these string
diagrams provide some natural language
for talking about active inference
um and I would encourage you to try if
anyone working on natural business for
me to take a look and see if they would
be useful to you in some way
and in particular focused on some other
what I was calling the main ingredients
of active inference so that were
generated models the way you update them
and free energy and we saw sort of ways
you can describe all those Notions in
the string diagrams and the thing that I
think is useful about them is that they
give you a nice representational
language of just drawing pictures of
your generative models and composing
them like hierarchical models and so on
they also let you do the reasoning
because you can do probability Theory
with them so you can actually reason
about what's going on in active events
just with the diagrams themselves
um there's loads of electricity in the
future obviously we can keep absorbing
more of the of the work without an
active inference into the into the
diagrams
um a bit more interestingly
um
I we introduced this new notion at the
end
um of how to make free energy
compositional
in particularly we gave this definition
of vfe for an open system now so it has
a generative model which can have inputs
we call just the open vfb and it's been
very interesting what people think of
this definition we we introduce however
it seems meaningful
secondly um well throughout the topic I
get to talk about just minimizing free
energy and that's what I said probably
the vfp if I didn't say how you do it so
um in fact this is normally done with
these various algorithms with message
passing algorithms so they're an
important part of accurate for instance
active inference as well and I think it
would be great to include these in the
in the setup by having some diagrammatic
story of them
um there's also lots of other questions
around so one of them is that I talked
about these two Notions updating with
respect to soft observations and I think
normally people tend to focus on child
observations so they perhaps haven't not
everyone has heard of these before
um but it's very natural to treat the
soft ones when you're working this
compositional setup
and so there you start to wonder about
which of these the Pearl style of dating
or the Jeffree style updating is more
natural to think of that in the context
of cognition
and maybe we'll say okay one really BFE
updating is the one you should be
thinking about that's probably the claim
active infants would make but it should
be nice to think about how this relates
to the other two is it better support of
this approximating the former or the
latter style of sort of precise updating
and then finally we can try and connect
this up to as much lots of further
topics I mentioned um I continue I'm
interested in this notion of
compositional intelligence so it would
be nice to to connect this now to topics
in Ai and so on
um and think about how it relates to
other basically applications of category
theory in AI in particular this is also
this whole world of categorical
cybernetics I mentioned at the beginning
um and I'd like to connect this a bit
more precisely with what people are
doing there with their stories in terms
of lenses and so on
and something else we were also
interested in that I mentioned is that
we got into the topic by thinking about
Consciousness and there's lots of ways
as a major theory of cognition there's
been just loads of reversals for how
active inference is related to
Consciousness and it'd be nice to see
how those can be described formally and
in this setup and however the streaming
diagrammatic approach helps you make any
more sense of those so that's something
we'd love to do in future
um and I just like to say thanks again
to all of you for listening and yep I'd
love to go to a discussion thanks
thank you Sean for the wonderful
presentation
thank you I will first pass to Ali for
opening remark
please
uh thank you Daniel
um thanks so much Sean for your really
fascinating uh presentation
um I truly enjoyed it uh so I have a
number of questions uh so let me Begin
by asking
um uh the first one
um so you know uh when Bob kirkey and
others uh took hamiltonian formulation
of quantum mechanics and uh kind of
turned it into uh the string diagram
formulation of it
um namely ZX calculus uh the claim was
that I mean regardless of its possible
Verity but the claim was that one of the
advantages of looking at quantum
mechanics in terms of string diagrams is
uh is more than uh it's more than just a
convenient way of looking at a Quantum
formulation and it actually unveils some
properties of quantum mechanics that
would be uh extremely difficult to see
with hamiltonian formulation and uh even
in some of their papers uh they claim
one one of the reasons for uh somehow
the
um stagnant development in Quantum
Technologies and quantum theory is uh is
exactly related to uh the difficulty of
working uh with hamiltonian formulation
so uh would you say string diagram
formulation of active inference kind of
uh takes a similar approach to uh
somehow providing more than just handy
tool for representing active inference
modeling and actually it kind of uh
opens up new possibilities for further
developments of active inference Theory
uh possibilities which would somehow uh
I don't know impossible or at least
extremely difficult for the current
traditional formulation of active
inference
um to see in the current formulation of
active inference
I think so that's amazing question yeah
um yeah I would agree I think the the
you know my the idea for work I also
actually in this categorical quantum
mechanics area talked about so string
diagrams for quantum theory and
everything and I agree that
um that language helps you talk about
other things
that you would maybe never get around to
so much in in other mathematical
conversations of quantum theory these
are these things that make use of the
the tensor that the the composition a
lot so
if this led to stagnation in quantum
theories probably because people weren't
focusing as much on the tensor and
entanglement and stuff which
um became very Central obviously like in
the end that that's what people needed
to to do Quantum Computing and stuff so
now you what people are doing with
quantum theory is includes going for
computing where they're drawing these
circuits and so you're drawing they're
basically you know like string diagrams
describing sometimes these string
diagrams sometimes they just use the
slightly different conventions for
Quantum circuits but it's similarly a
compositional language where
you've got tensor products certainly as
in things running in parallel states of
these products so that you can talk
about entanglement and so on
um as
is the language that makes it very
immediate to to represent that because
you just draw a box of two eyes you know
name because entangled State and it
makes you want to plug these things
together and compose them
which is what you want to do in Quantum
computing
so I think similarly
um if you never use that kind of
language you might
think of a system often as a fixed thing
and not about the way it interacts with
other ones so much and that could lead
to
overlooking all sorts of things so
that's true in any area and I think in
active inference
um is certainly very true I think it is
natural to think compositionally in this
way because you're
you're wanting to talk about generative
models being composed from pieces and
maybe thinking about how the whole brain
works in relation to interactions
between parts of it and so on
so if you never use this kind of
compositional view there is stuff you
would miss I think I think in some sense
people weren't as behind already because
they already were working kind of
compositionally right because they're
using these Bayesian networks diagrams
like the dags and the way they're
normally drawn a very close they're like
they are basically the string diagrams
they just don't do the the equations and
the rewriting of the of the diagrams so
it's not as far back maybe as quantum
theory was in the sense that people are
thinking compositionally but it's like
it feels I just want to go one step
further to having a fully compositional
language or working in where you know
you have the advantage now that you can
just talk about taking a whole model and
plugging it into another one and it has
a completely clear formal meaning and so
on which I think is what you want to do
in areas like active infants so going
from the diagrams as they're currently
used to string diagrams is like The
Logical next step and in terms of new
stuff it lets you do I think
um an example with something like this
open BFE thing I guess so it's
um
if you're just always thinking about
just a generative model meaning on
without inputs you might not think of a
notion I'm not saying this is
necessarily the right notion but you
might not think about this problem of
how you want to give your definition for
some payment
is allowed to have inputs as well and
once you have that you know have
definition you can sort of apply to
parts of a composite system more easily
so it becomes
um more natural to to use
compositionally so that's the kind of
thing where without something like
string diagrams it people can end up
overlooking it it wouldn't be impossible
to do without them right you need to
talk about this notion of a kind of open
generative model which just means
throwing away so mechanisms to make
things be inputs
um but you could miss it you know and
you but you really won't once you start
thinking categorically
thank you ollie please continue if you
would like
uh thanks so much so uh yeah my uh other
um perhaps related question is
um I mean comparing uh this kind of
formulation to uh this recent uh
formulation of Constructor theory in
terms of string diagrams or categorical
formulation of Constructor Theory
before going into this question uh you
see you mentioned that this project is a
part of a larger Pro a larger project
for developing collective intelligence
right so uh the similar similar kind of
situation happens for Constructor theory
in which it is a kind of meta theory
that tries to somehow
um uh discriminate between the uh
possibilities of physical laws as
opposed to counterfactual laws and how
physical laws
how there can be a theory against for
the emergence of possible physical laws
so uh in this sense can you we just say
this kind of formulation categorical
category theoretical formulation or
um possibly this specific string diagram
formulation of active inference uh or
maybe other theories of Consciousness it
can be seen as a kind of providing a
path toward developing a kind of meta
Theory Of Consciousness and possibly
unifying many different strands of uh
theories of Consciousness into to um
I don't know a holistic picture that can
somehow be
compared and
positively reconciled with uh with one
another and ultimately reaching uh the
ultimate theory of uh Consciousness or
uh I don't know do you see this line of
work uh I mean providing
enough evidence for this line of
development research or I don't know
somehow
maybe even not specifically
Consciousness but uh unifying the
different aspects of
um cognition intelligence and
Consciousness all together so
um
keep giving me like ideal um selling
points so yeah there's also something I
would I would like to say you know I
mean that that um
yeah I I tend to think of it that way in
that you know my background is in
applying category to just lots of topics
and I so naturally do think of it as
quite a unifying language and you know
the the ground and Consciousness that I
mentioned was building on earlier what
we did on looking at integrated
information Theory Of Consciousness
which in the end basically was done in
terms of categorical probability so it's
like the same setup of the diagrams and
so we kind of wanted to do the same
thing for directive inference so
um
there it's like we've taken both of
these things and put them in this common
language you could have put them in a
Common Language a probability Theory
before but I think you know I do have an
intuition that
um there is something more clear about
it does make it easier to get a
conceptual graph but if there's I think
once you've done it this way and
somehow also yeah the diagrammatic view
does make it much easier to compare them
so the Hope was basically to
you know it still is to keep going and
to keep
understanding various Notions in that
language those things I've looked at on
cognitive science I've also done this
way since the three of them conceptual
spaces
have worked on creating that in terms of
diagrams and so on so I would love to
see basically many theories put into
this language to make it easier to
compare them yeah you could try and
compelling directly already but I think
you want one clear formalization to put
them all in and I would say that the
categories and the diagrams is the right
one to pick because
um it tends to just give a very clear
conceptual view of things the question
is whether you have some Theory that's
very important where
the things categories are good at just
doesn't quite
capture the essence of what you want to
talk about there but for things like
active inference and
and IIT so far it's it's very natural
because on a case of IIT it's about
talking about how integrated something
is so you basically want to talk about
the opposite of that which is something
being decomposed and the diagrams
basically that you talk about parts and
how they're related which is what you
need to make sense of that notion of
integration so it's very natural there
but yeah I would love to basically to
see um various aspects of cognitive
science
um understood categorically that's
something I'd love to do myself as well
um
and as a you know the hope would be then
to try and gain insights from all of
them you know and build a theory it's
not the category Theory itself is a
theory of cognition or Consciousness
it's just a very useful language for
relating them and then
it would be very exciting to see
something you know natively defined in
terms of Academy Theory as well at the
end
and there's a feeling that some of
what's going on in applied categories
Theory I think like in categorical
cybernetics and so on is kind of taking
that that approach for perhaps some of
the first time previously I've always
thought category theory is basically
take existing things and you get a
really nice abstract view of them but
now I think if people are comfortable
enough with it that they're like sort of
defining things categorically from from
the outset in areas like that yeah
awesome well
yeah I I have many thank you that's a
great question there's like ideal
questions
you've pointed and we've explored a
little bit of the utility and the
Simplicity and how that could help with
accessibility and rigor and
applicability all these awesome things
leading to
reaccounting and reframing consolidating
as well as discovering some new trails
between for example expected free energy
and variational free energy
looking at the equations you might be
able to say that they rhyme
but you would be many many lines deep
into understanding what if any
generalizations could Encompass the both
of them
so that that was just a very
Salient example
a few different kinds of questions so
how is time treated
in category Theory or how does active
inference treat time today
and how do you see the way that time is
treated we talk about discrete time and
continuous time generative models then
there's the past present and future
multi-agent systems Federated or
asynchronous communication so how is
time treated
and how does that give us a different
grasp on dynamical modeling
um
thank you I think that's already
I'd love to have a better answer for
that basically I think it's a tough one
you know so at the moment yeah in the
talk so far I've just talked about
discrete time and that's sort of very
easy to treatment Invasion network setup
and with the these kind of thing
diagrams because you can just lay out
the discrete time steps as processes in
your picture like we see here where we
have the end and time steps here
but
um I don't have anything
satisfying worked out yet to say about
how you would treat
a continuous time case search I think is
important in active inference you'd like
to basically
um
take I guess basically what you want to
do is take the way that you describe
this thing with the end time steps and
kind of have a form of folding it
together and just say okay but you're
unpacking this thing end times
and then you can take that thing and
imagine you know this abstract view of
unpacking it just not discreetly anymore
in this continuous way so that you can
capture something like a differential
equation and a definition of continuous
time thing and active inference
um
I
yeah so you can certainly work with
continuous time thinking in the sense of
you know the stuff going on in
categorical cybernetics or sort of
categorical systems cereal I guess it
would be called act world is kind of you
know it has continuous time dynamical
systems and talks about plugging them
together but that that diagram is sort
of just relating their variables though
is my understanding it's not like the
diagram isn't exactly showing the time
and in some sense they kind of have to
synchronize I think you know it's not an
area I'm totally familiar with so it
would be yeah it would have been really
really cool basically
have this work and then have another
part of it talking about
you know like we've done for discrete
time here having a nice description of
of a continuous time case I think it
will end up being some some work to take
that into account
um there would be really nice to see so
it just needs the right abstraction I
think or
yeah taking a picture like this not
drawing the time steps as like bits in
your diagram but just saying
you know that it's like this B thing
with like a feedback loop basically is
what this is describing and then giving
a semantics to that in terms of time
evolution
um to give a continuous version of this
for example with like State confirming
continuously in observations
for each time step
um in general I wouldn't say there's
like an answer to the question of how is
time treated in category Theory there
wouldn't really be one answer because
categories can be so generally
um they tend to be very effective for
the just for discrete things in general
like like algebra and so on because they
kind of are screen in some sense that
the composition is discrete so
continuous aspects and things like
continuous time tend to be more
difficult in a sense or they're just
sort of inside the morphisms as it were
they're not
in the composition so it doesn't end up
looking like this when you're composing
continuously
um
but yeah I think there will be people in
act who've sort of
would come come at you with this
particular answer so they've got a way
they like to treat continuous time
um no I'm I'm just not familiar with
yeah yeah
cool
a little bit of a more educational or
applied question
so how do we go about drawing and
learning to draw is there a software
package is there a way that we can get a
step-by-step process to building that
familiarity with like when I see this
shape then here's what I know and then
how do we know what we can and can't do
and does that drawing software flag us
or do we need to send it to a friend so
how do we look at something and then
part one build up the motifs in our own
aesthetic understanding so that we can
understand the compositionality of this
as you do today and as we all do today
for example for language English
and then part two how do we go from
having built that Motif based
compositional understanding to like
now what can we do and then when are we
just totally freewheeling and off the
rails or the free energy principle or
like Does anything go if the motifs
allow it
um yeah I wish I I should I should have
a standard answer the best way to learn
string diagrams I think if I'm going to
talk about it like this so you've
prompted me to to come up with that I
don't have something on top of my head
that's the best way but there's so much
stuff out there you know if you're I
think it tends to be because
yeah if you want to get really
comfortable with the diagrams he was
learning category theory in some sense
but it's not like you need to learn all
of category Theory it's kind of a
relatively modern offshoot in this
applied category very well that's very
diagrammatically focused
and there will be various nice
introductions out there to using them
um another way is to so
I'm trying to think I'm pretty sure
recently yeah there was a nice figure
that came out there was an introduction
to string diagrams for computer
scientists for example so there tends to
be different introductions kind of for
different audiences because they just
want to pick categories
um that
um that those people are familiar with
right so they can actually have some
examples you could just learn the
diagrams totally up straightly but it
helps to have some examples
um and you know the old category three
textbooks are all things mathematicians
have looked at and a lot of people
haven't heard of so they're not
particularly helpful so there's like you
know Bob has paper categories for the
practicing physicist it's aim to
physicists that would basically
introduce string diagrams to them
there's this recent computer science one
I know there's some work going on in
producing one for cognitive science
which I think would be really good
um having an introduction yeah to the to
the string diagrams for those people
um so you basically look for one in an
area you're comfortable with and if you
find it in paper on it but
um it would be nice to have a good
online resource I guess right that
gathers these together so people can can
just see a great guide for the all the
introductions
if you do something like um
yeah there's courses you can do in a
sense of the
um Bobs but but in the case of learning
Quantum there's something like Bob's
long book about Kissinger picturing
contemporary processors that's the kind
of thing I learned from like it was in
the form of electrical so it's basically
the same book so because then there's
loads of exercises that will make you
have to reason with string diagrams and
then you pick the rules up because at
first it's yeah you don't you don't have
the same intuition obviously but the
rules what can I do with these can I
slide them around like this or whatever
but it doesn't take too long to get
quite used to it I think which is the
nice thing about them they're kind of
natural they're just these elastic
strings and boxes you know and you have
a sort of geometrical intuition
depends on the lack of exercises are the
way I'd recommend getting used to using
them
um I didn't use any like software in a
sense of the diagrams I draw on this
program called ticks it but it doesn't
like tell you how string diagrams work
or anything it's just for drawing them
um but I know there's more work to
develop you know libraries like the
algebraic Julia project is sort of like
an applied category Theory
um language but I wouldn't know if it
was recommended as a way to First learn
categories
and
yeah so I would recommend finding a nice
introductory paper in whatever field
you're most used to playing with some
exercises to get really used to them
um for causal models there's this paper
Robin and I put out it's not necessarily
the very first place to learn screen
diagrams but the game is to to introduce
to people who've heard of calls and
models saying a sense of pearl so it's
Bayesian networks basically but maybe
the course interpretation of them
um to get them used to string diagrams
and this this paper hopes to be a little
bit introductory as well yeah
cool Ollie please
uh thank you so uh getting back to the
question about the time representation
uh in this formulation uh so uh I take
it that this kind of the formulation of
Bayesian inference I mean category
theoretical formulation of Bayesian for
instance is largely based on Toby Spritz
definition of Markov uh categories as a
CD categories right so as far as I
understand it uh Fritz paper uh kind of
one of its basic assumptions is this
kind of unidirectional
inference I mean from earlier times to
later times right
or in other words the prediction uh but
uh
um in uh Quantum formulation of active
inference or
Quantum active inference uh there's this
attempt to also develop uh the
retroduction aspect of inference as well
right uh so would you say uh this recent
formulation uh can also be accounted for
uh for this kind of retroduction you
know the words uh can this formulation
be reconciled with a Quantum bayesianism
as well
yeah because to add uh one more context
here uh in uh I think it was in kirkens
beckon's paper there was this clear
distinction between classical Bayesian
uh inference and non-classical Bayesian
inference uh which the classical one
does not
um I mean allow for uh the retroduction
but non-classical Bayesian inference uh
can be applied for both prediction and
retroduction as well
oh okay yeah I would love to be a bit
more familiar with the the quantum
active infant stuff basically to compare
a bit so I'm not I'm not as familiar
with the sort of
and then retro sorry obviously the
elevation prediction is retro
retroduction yeah prediction and
retroduction yeah so I think
um
yeah I would have to compare with this
the another paper member box paper
problem on both forms of Asian inference
to see what they say they're about the
classical one
um can you give some intuition as to why
isn't something you can do basically
basically the the Retro one because if
that's in general probabilities then it
will be true in some sense here right so
you know here it's just being modeled in
this probabilistic category and so at
the moment they're separate in that you
know you have the model which basically
goes forward and then you do your
updating to try and
approximate something going back but you
don't really have like this one
um
yeah yeah so uh so um I mean the whole
idea was that uh for a predictive uh
quantum mechanics uh we only need to
account for the inference from earlier
times later times but uh if we want to
account for retroductive quantum
mechanics as well uh we need to somehow
uh account for uh because as we know
um not every
um I mean Quantum formulation uh follows
the bell's principle of local causality
uh so uh that's uh I mean in order to
account for all the entanglement
phenomena and so on and we need to
somehow uh put these this bi-directional
uh inference into our model uh so uh
yeah that was the basic idea behind
developing this kind of non-classical
Bayesian and Prince
um
does it have something to do with like
the unitary evolution in content Theory
the way it has this reversible thing or
is it
exactly yeah yeah
that was the interest of it
yeah and so you don't expect to have
something like that classically
basically where you have this
reversible thing built in well yeah I I
so I wouldn't expect to see uh
that exact feature here in the sense of
you know if it's
treated if it's basically something that
you can't uh have in classical
probabilities it's not gonna it won't
exist in this category matter plus
because that's I think that would be
basically the same category they would
use in that paper and they were dagger
combat categories
and they'll work with metal something
like this metal plus category but the
classical case
um if it's just a general like it's left
of a sort of physical notion but it's
just an idea that the the model comes
with a forward part and an accurate part
then I think that's the kind of
here obviously how you go from forward
path to approximate this backward thing
but the sort of lens type view of what's
going on that's more voted in category
cybernetics would be imagining I think
the model kind of carrying this backward
inference process with it as well so
there it's you know for each forward
part of the model they would
um have this approximate inference sort
of Channel stored with it
um so I don't know if that would address
what you're after but it would have
either a backward and forward part
together yeah
well Ollie do you have any kind of
closing slash opening remarks or
questions or where where do you see this
going from the active inference side
what what is this bring to us
and what is opened through
what has happened
largely this year in active inference
and category Theory
well actually I'm really excited to see
this line of development uh an active
inference Theory and uh as you know I'm
a big big fan of meta theories and uh
all kinds of
unification theories and so on so uh
it's uh I don't know I kind of
have this feeling at this time that this
line of development in active inference
uh Theory uh is I mean it looks quite
promising uh especially for
um
kind of tying up all the Loose Ends and
transcending and many many other areas
and discourses and ultimately reaching a
kind of uh coherent picture of
quote-unquote reality whatever it means
so uh yeah these kinds of development I
mean the last year we had a tremendous
advances in Bayesian mechanical theories
and in recent month we have this
fabulous line of research in category
theoretical accounts of active inference
My Hope Is that ultimately these
different strands can be unified into as
I said coherent and overarching
framework so exciting times
so do you mean that you're thinking of
it as um it sounded like you're
basically alluding to the
I think I have working on in cognition
and work going on into physics going
together right like one really really
matter really exactly so yeah the I the
idea behind Bayesian mechanics uh one of
its uh premises or assertions was that
uh there isn't any clear uh distinction
between uh cognitive and non-cognitive
things or agents and uh they rest uh and
a Continuum and it's uh I mean the same
kind of mathematical technology can be
applied both for inert and uh conscious
agents or in the absentient agents uh or
whatever we choose to call them uh so
yeah this overarching uh Theory uh I
mean unveiled many interesting uh
phenomena regarding uh well
self-organizing systems and
um it changed the whole perspective uh
about how we can look at and Define even
define consciousness cognition
intelligence sentience and all of these
related terms uh so my hope is that uh
category theoretical accountability
active inference can also be uh used for
clearly seeing many of these
emerging elements in Bayesian mechanics
and active inference Theory and
hopefully
well gaining some
interesting and potentially
groundbreaking insights
that'd be wonderful yeah I
love to apply for those topics yeah and
I'd be very curious to see how
categories can come in there sorry
Daniel yeah oh yeah I'll just give my
closing thoughts then then to you Sean
just just a few loose notes that again
open probably more than they close
Ali was right in
suggesting and and expressing that
Bayesian mechanics recently has helped
us
develop a Continuum of active and
passive systems so-called living and
non-living or inanimate and animate and
that brings us to another dialectic to
resolve which is life and mind which is
where the physical and the cognitive
science come together you said they're
on a Continuum maybe we could say
they're on a quantitium
and what language could express
such work well right now we're speaking
in English with the active inference
ontology dialect
however the phonemes are not
intrinsically meaningful the um in a
Markov blanket or category does not mean
something it's it's a sound
and so the
string diagram language and
representation
I see as a way to fuse and integrate
semantics into the syntax of the actual
inscription
which enables us to
generalize in new ways also recognizing
string diagrams or not everything or and
so on
and then with all of these intersecting
vectors from cognitive and the physical
sciences
we are able to take the compositional
cartographic approach
for cognitive ecosystems and talk about
diverse intelligences
biological Quantum classical
architectures all of these synthetic
intelligences and so it's super exciting
and
I appreciate again your visit and look
forward to
people's curiosity taking them and also
the development of tools and educational
materials that that make this easier and
then being able to display and use
something where the meaning
is primal
rather than like well this letter
represents this
it already introduces such a space
between
the analytical representation and
really the string diagram
which exists isomorphically with it
hmm
yes but it's very exciting way of
thinking yeah yeah it sounds like you're
you're um
advocating a kind of structural ontology
kind of thing in some sense right
whether you're taking the
compositional stretch of what's going on
to really be the meaning already be the
the real thing that's there not just
like
I don't know yeah we could talk about it
for a while I'm actually but I would
love to yeah see string diagrams and you
know other other approaches I'm sure
that um
pick that role and you've got me very
excited about this kind of unification
that's going on
thank you again Sean you're always
welcome and we look forward to seeing
where this all goes
yeah thanks thanks again for having me
yeah really great discussion thank you
thank you so much
all right bye thanks